sea gdx igual a equis cuadrada menos
cinco si f de gtx es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de x cuadrada más 4 cuál de las
siguientes describe a efe de x ok una
pregunta interesante una forma de
resolverla es intentar hacer la
composición para cada una de estas fx si
ésta fuera de fx entonces
efe compuesta de gtx va a ser igual a
bueno cada vez que veas una x en f la
reemplazaremos por gtx entonces nos
quedará la raíz cuadrada deje de x +
pero esto es igual a bueno x es igual a
equis cuadrada menos 5 entonces es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de x cuadrada menos 5
esto es gd x y a esto hay que sumarle 1
lo cual es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x
cuadrada y menos cinco más uno es igual
a menos cuatro pero no es lo que tenemos
arriba nos piden la raíz cuadrada de x
cuadrada más 4 así que esta no es la
opción correcta podemos intentar con la
siguiente
efe dgt x es igual y cada vez que veamos
a x la reemplazaremos x gtx
entonces me queda la raíz cuadrada de 7
x 9 es decir esto es lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada de gx pero x es igual a x
cuadrada menos 5 + 9 y esto es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de x cuadrada más
menos 59 eso es lo mismo que cuatro más
4 que es exactamente lo que nos piden
entonces si fx es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de x más 9 ya podemos decir que
f dgt x es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x
cuadrada más 4 así que esta es nuestra
respuesta correcta